now police in scotland are investigating
allegations that two of their own
officers were involved in a child abuse
ring in glasgow it follows testimony
given to sky news by one victim who says
she recognized an officer who sexually
abused her she says he was the same man
who sometimes picked her up and took her
home after she went missing data
examined by sky news also shows a huge
gulf between the number of children
referred for help as victims of modern
slavery compared to the number of
attempted prosecutions for the crime now
the following report by our home editor
jason farrell does contain distressing
details about child grooming
i was
about 12 13.
it was just one day he was like i need
you to do something for me
and well you don't really have a choice
in it tony louise has waived her
anonymity to tell how she was a child
victim of modern slavery she was groomed
sold for sex and claims the men who paid
to rape her even included police
officers
it started when a man she thought was
her boyfriend asked her to have sex with
another man i was kind of like i don't
i don't really want to do this and he
was like well it's too late now like
i've i've already told him that you're
going to do it
and that was the first time that i was
sold for money
often
so he sold you for sex
at first it was only like
once or twice a week
that i would have to leave school
and then it got to like every day it got
to the point where i wasn't even making
it up to school he was picking me up at
the end of my mum's street twenty years
ago the charity barnardos first
suggested around a hundred children were
being sold for sex in glasgow over the
years concerns have resurfaced
especially around the area of govern
hill when we began investigating three
years ago a local sex worker told us
she'd seen a child being sold for sex in
one of glasgow's poorest suburbs she
looked about
13 14 if that if that she was very thin
very small
but she i could see that she was
definitely working you know she was
walking around and looking around i said
are you working and this man came out
from absolutely nowhere
absolutely nowhere and said she's she's
fine it's our problem and i said no just
wanted to swear she said she's fine i
said are you with her then i said yeah
htc i'm my uncle for boys modern slavery
mostly involves criminal exploitation
such as selling drugs with girls most
often it's sexual exploitation sky news
analysis of data in scotland found 349
children have been given a reasonable
grounds decision under the national
referral mechanism as being victims of
modern slavery yet data from the last
five years shows only eight attempted
prosecutions and not one conviction
we spoke to one woman who didn't want to
be identified who claimed she'd been
groomed from the age of eight by a
shopkeeper
they were giving me drink at a young age
and [ __ ] cigarettes and then
so he was grooming you
well yeah i
how far would the abuse go then
he touched my breast and then it went
from that to the next extreme
aged 15 she had a drug addiction and was
regularly exploited sometimes by groups
of men
all these guys came in
and i was like
one thing led to another
and they were all gang-raping me
i didn't think i was getting out of
there to life
is this the this is the street where you
jumped out the window
the street we drove down where anne
marie says she was gang raped is the
same street where tony louise says she
was abused in what is now an abandoned
housing block she says she was sold to
up to 30 men a day
men from all walks of life among them
she claims were two police officers
do you know for sure that you were
raped by
police officers yes
100
how do you know that because some of
them were the ones that took me home
when i'd been reported muslim
so i've seen them in their uniform you
are kidding me nope
they knew what i was the whole time
so the people taking you home in the
police car
had had sex with me when i was underage
she says one officer abused her several
times over six months did he try and
pretend it hadn't happened i think it's
work mode is different to
i'm going to rape a child mode
like it was never acknowledged
tony louise eventually escaped her
situation she didn't report the police
officers for fear it wouldn't be
believed but alleged crimes against her
locked by the police include 29 rapes
there was an investigation but despite
one charge it didn't reach court when i
went to the police
one of the police officers turned down
to me and went you've got a very active
imagination for a wee girl aren't you
tony louise has now reported the alleged
incidents involving police and in a
statement police scotland said a new
report of child exploitation involving
police officers from 2014 was received
by police scotland on the 9th of may
2022 this report is now being
investigated by specialist officers from
our national sexual crimes unit and we
are unable to comment further at this
stage
it's hard to get a handle on the scale
of this but we've spoken to a number of
grassroots charities who say it is a
problem and one who said off the record
that organized child sexual abuse was a
hidden pandemic across the central belt
of scotland
police scotland told us they wanted to
reassure anyone who's been a victim of
sexual assault that time is no bar to
reporting and all allegations will be
fully investigated regardless of the
identity of the perpetrator
jason farrell sky news glasgow